kelly mock économiste ancien député ps
au parlement européen hans ou d'un
membre de la france insoumise bonsoir
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
les deux camps j'ai nommé l'exécutif
d'un côté et les syndicats est plus
déterminé on va dire la cgt notamment
personne ne s'en vouloir désarmer
quelle est votre réaction par rapport à
tout ça
comment vous pensez que ça va se
terminer on est en plein rapport de
force
le gouvernement ne semble pas vouloir
lâcher la lettre d'edouard philippe aux
syndicats la teste fermement
quand il dit que il ouvre une conférence
sur le financement mais qu'en même temps
il ferme la porte à l'augmentation soit
disant du coût du travail et qu'il y
aura l'âge déquilibre in signer dans le
texte
bon la messe est dite on sait que dans
cette conférence
le medef va s'opposer à l'augmentation
des cotisations et la seule variable
d'ajustement puisque la valeur du point
manifestement sera indexé soit sur les
salaires soit sur l'inflation comme de
loi s'y était engagée la seule la seule
variable d'ajustement possible dans ce
cas là c'est là la durée de cotisation
et c'est pour ça qu'il a mis la vie des
clips dans son cou dans le point 8 de sa
lettre les syndicats le savent les
salariés aujourd'hui savent très bien
que le gouvernement ne lâchera pas et le
gouvernement joue sur ce qu'on appelle
vulgairement le pourrissement de la
grève en sachant que les gens sont déjà
à quasiment deux mois de grève et qu'ils
pourront pas tenir très longtemps et que
l'opinion publique se lassera c'est le
pari que fait le gouvernement
mais ça veut dire quoi que 60% des
français qui soutiennent le mouvement de
grève et qui sont contre cette réforme
vous en prendre pour leur frais vont
devoir s'y résigner ça veut dire ça
selon vous la grève est pas si un peuple
est un beaucoup de gens ont jeudi
justement c'est pour cent des français
qui soutiennent la crise justement elle
et elle et elle est plutôt populaire et
à l'époque de des mouvements contre
juppé les journalistes appelés à faire
grève par procuration etc c'est un peu
c'est un peu ce qui se passe ça gêne
beaucoup de gens mais les gens sont bien
contents que les salariés du secteur
public qui ont la possibilité plus que
de faire grève soit à l'avant-garde de
cette bataille qui va qui va toucher
tout le monde parce que les salariés du
privé savent très bien que en passant
dans ce régime de retraite la par points
ils vont y perdre c'est intéressant ce
que vous ne dites pas ce qu'on n'en
parle pas souvent des salariés du privé
qui effectivement sont une forme de
majorité un petit peu silencieuse c'est
j'ose dire on les voit pas dans la rue
est-ce que ça va vraiment aussi pourquoi
pas leur profiter seconde mangane sont
que des effectivement des régimes
spéciaux des métiers spécifiques qui
vont se retrouver avec quelques
concessions il y en a déjà eu dans les
pilotes de ligne les avocats même s'ils
sont toujours pas content effectivement
évidemment les salariés du privé qu'on
n'entend pas qu'ils vont en prendre pour
leur grade dans cette réforme
les régimes spéciaux ces 3 % des
salariés
on entend beaucoup l'art en ce moment
puisqu'on ce qu'on dit pas c'est que la
réforme concerne tous les salariés que
et que à partir du moment où on passe à
un mode de calcul sur
sur toute la carrière où je des 25
meilleures années dans le système actuel
pour les salariés du privé
il y aura une baisse généralisée des
pensions est d'ailleurs la philosophie
du rapport delevoye s'était c'était ça
c'était de proposer un système où les
gens choisissent et soit de partir avant
avec une pension plus faible soit de
partir de partir beaucoup plus tard que
62 ans avec une pension plus importante
et la cfdt avaient avaient acquiescé ce
ce schéma là sauf que lorsque edouard
philippe a demandé à delevoye de
remettre sa copie avant l'été il s'est
posé la question à oui mais si tout le
monde de décider se décider à partir à
62 ans par exemple est ce que on aurait
les moyens de financer la chose et c'est
là qu'il a introduit la borne d'âge à 64
à 64 ans et c'est là où les syndicats
ont dit mais c'est pas possible puisque
déjà 62 ans il ya des gens qui ont
cotisé plus de 42 ans qui en droit de
partir là ça veut dire que on leur
demande de cotiser 44 ans donc le bis
bis entre la cfdt et le gouvernement est
venue de la met au fond
cette réforme à la halla halla un
objectif clé qui est sanctuarisé que
dans le partage du gâteau il y aura pas
une part plus importante consacrée aux
retraites et donc au salaire parce que
les retraites il faut pas oublier que
dans le système par répartition c'est du
salaire la cotisation qui va payer la
retraite en fin de vie le salaire à vie
entre guillemets c'est une partie du
salaire socialisé c'est ce que les
syndicalistes appellent le salaire
différé et le fait que le gouvernement
dise le coût du travail ne baissera pas
ça veut dire que dans le partage entre
les salaires et les profits
la part des salaires incluant le salaire
socialisé n'augmenteraient
n'augmenteraient pas alors que la part
des salaires a déjà baissé par rapport à
ce qu'elle représentait au cours des
trente glorieuses
ça veut dire que dans la conférence de
financement il ne sera pas possible de
distribuer une part plus importante du
gâteau aux salariés que ce qu'il
s'agisse d'une augmentation de salaire
ou d'une augmentation de cotisations
sociales c'est interressant ce
ne dites pas ce que vous êtes un
économiste avant tout vous justement en
tant qu'expert quand on nous dit cette
réforme était nécessaire comme de
l'autre côté le gouvernement nous dit
elle est juste et équitable vous qu'est
ce que vous pensez vous préconiseriez
quoi alors c'est compliqué en quelques
minutes mais cette réforme une cliente
avec ce que ce que le gouvernement
appelle les politiques de l'offre
c'est-à-dire et politique qui consiste à
redresser comme il le dit le taux de
marge c'est à dire à réduire le coût du
travail pour augmenter les profits pour
être que ça simplement aux
téléspectateurs et l'idée c'est que les
profits servent à l'investissement à
l'innovation à la compétitivité etc
mais le vrai sujet quand on regarde les
choses de près c'est qu'aujourd'hui 85 %
des profits nets après impôts servent à
verser des dividendes alors que
auparavant il ya trente ans avant que le
capitalisme financier comme on dit
aujourd'hui ne s'installe les deux tiers
des profits servent à financer
l'investissement
bon aujourd'hui l'essentiel des profits
ça sert à financer les dividendes qui
sont les revenus des 0,1 pour cent les
plus riches doit un accroissement des
inégalités et ça commence à se voir
c'est pour ça que cette réforme n'était
absolument pas populaire parce que les
gens se rendent bien compte que on veut
pas affecter une part plus importante du
gâteau aux salaires et donc pour
retraite
par contre on sanctuarise un partage
salaires profits en faveur des profits
sauf que les profits ne servent pas à
l'économie réelle ne savent pas
l'investissement ne servent pas l'emploi
ils servent à distribuer des dividendes
qui sont eux-mêmes replacer sur les
marchés financiers pour faire monter le
cours des actions et la valeur
patrimoniale des entreprises c'est ça
qui est en train de se passer
oui mais on doute on tend les actions
honte voilà il ya beaucoup d'argent ça
va profiter aux salariés puisque les
retraites seront en partie justement
dans ce
système sur les marchés si vous regardez
de près les choses on vous rendez compte
que l'activité des marchés actions s'est
essentiellement des rachats d'actions
l'émission en tant que tel d'action
c'est marginal
or c'est l'émission d'actions qui
financent investissent pour c'est
marginal j'irai même plus loin
aujourd'hui des entreprises font du
profit l auto financer leurs
investissements à 93% et tout ce que ne
savent pas les gens ont leurs vêtements
les bassines avec la dette sociale qui
par ailleurs sera résorbé à l'horizon
et c'est pas vrai que on n'a pas les
ressources pour équilibrer le régime de
retraite avec les excédents de lait
branche famille accidents du travail
et maladie et chômage
il ya de quoi les il ya de quoi
équilibrer le régime à long terme et ce
que ne savent pas des gens c'est que la
dette privée des entreprises
elle explose et à la dette privée
aujourd'hui elle est de 133 % du pib et
la dette des entreprises 6 c'est 73% et
elle ne sert pas à financer
l'investissement
elle sert à financer des opérations de
fusion-acquisition c'est à dire des
actes des achats d'actions et elle sert
à verser des dividendes
donc toute l'activité aujourd'hui
financière des entreprises ne sert pas à
financer l'investissement et l'emploi
c'est bien ça le sujet c'est que les
politiques de l'offre aussi cohérente
soit elle aujourd'hui ne russell pas
parce que la masse d'argent qui est à la
disposition des entreprises ne sert pas
un investissement merci en tout cas lima
- docks d'avoir été avec nous avoir
apporté votre analyse certes technique
mais utile merci à vous en tout cas
ancien député ps est entièrement de la
france insoumise merci à vous